today's sponsor is audible com audible
com has more than 180,000 audiobooks and
spoken word audio products get a free
audiobook of your choice it is free and
it is waiting for you like my book life
of the party which the audio book is
actually ten times better than the real
book at ww audible podcast.com backslash
bird cast also trip flip tuesday nights
8pm on travel channel that is it for ads
everybody today's guest one of my
favorite human beings in the world
literally i laughs today harder than
i've laughed in a quite a long time and
we have one of the most seamless
conversations i have ever had with this
gentleman he is a podcast machine with
literally three of the top ten podcasts
out there getting doug with hi doug
loves movies' the Benson interruption I
don't even know if that's podcast
anymore I just know that he has two of
them maybe it's just two of them he's
one of my favorite people I love hanging
out with him and we will be hanging out
together in DC June eleventh twelfth and
thirteenth where I'm a headline in the
DC improv and he's coming into a show
ladies and gentlemen it is my pleasure
to bring to you Doug Benson
yes but why don't you say something like
it started or something I should have
said it started I sort of said it
started um so this is about that's what
podcast used to be is just us talking
[ __ ] about people uh I guess it's still
a little bit of that but maybe not you
know isn't there a lot of talk lately
about how it's important to punch up and
set it down so you kind of have to you
know I may not attack people that are
below you in terms of success and what
now I think it's even see it's weird
when you tack up it's like if when
people saw hear people talk [ __ ] about
Louie or Kevin Hart you're like what the
[ __ ] you know that's true I guess but
you know there's always gonna be when
guys get that level of success there's
always gonna be people to meet like me
to go Louise brilliant and I'm still not
sure about Kevin Hart you know yeah I
mean I like him and that get hard movie
with Will Ferrell yeah he has one scene
in that movie that's the funniest thing
I've ever seen Kevin Hart do really yeah
where he like he's telling will ferrell
what its gonna be like out in the prison
yard in prison and he starts doing like
he starts playing all the characters
like all the different guys in the
prison yard yeah he like you know
changes his hat around and the changes
his face and does the different
characters and it's just really it's
really well done and they I think he's
already kind of getting into a ready
into a rut of just being manic and not
being not having a cleverness to it yeah
you know that that scene had there's the
movie was you know I didn't love it but
like yeah you know it's not to say I mac
i can't i'm doing exactly was just
talking about not doing is I'm punching
up but like there is a there is a there
is a character that you get cast as
playing into in movies and then they
want a lot of that so it's a lot of that
you know like the Chris Chris Tucker ya
know I bet I see it happen to every
great comic uh Steve Martin uh you know
but I dare say half of his movies he's
playing someone who's just frustrated
all the time and
and is upset yeah you know instead of
the funniest [ __ ] guy in the room you
know what I mean yeah then like you know
it sort of happened a little bit too
Chevie chase like he was really cool for
a few movies and then suddenly vacation
you know he turned this corner and then
he just had to play the bumbling [ __ ]
for the rest of his life yeah he was the
cool guy time was so cool in foul play
yeah and in Caddyshack and funny cool
yeah which is hard to do and once you've
got it you should run with it Eddie
Murphy has to play characters that
aren't as smart as his character yet as
characters he should be playing that's
so [ __ ] true what about Zack Zack is
you know been frustrated but then
Birdman came along and you know now he
can ride his ticket right as far as yeah
I guess film acting it's exactly he's
amazing we did it he's an amazing and
Birdman there's those long takes and he
he threw in a kind of a Galifianakis
move he mispronounced when he says
Martin Scorsese mispronounced is it yeah
he's like martin scorsees something like
that zach is one of the most under I
think underappreciated comet I don't
know the right word but I feel like he's
one of my favorite comics to watch but
he's someone all anyone wants to do is
go wolfpack now right goes onstage yes
his comedy his jokes that he writes and
the ones that he ad libs like he's it's
just the jokes are all they tend to just
be perfect you know like I used to do
Joe coughs with him or we just take
turns saying saying jokes cuz his short
he just does so many good short jokes
yeah you know like he's kind of a little
bit of a throwback to steven wright who
also never had clunky short jokes that's
hard to do it's hard to do a [ __ ] ton of
short jokes and get big glass with all
of them you know and that's and that's
where zach also he like pauses a long
time in between each joke cuz if you
just rattle them off some aren't gonna
get laughs you know like i was just
watching when i watch the final top 10
list on Letterman yeah I was like some
of these famous people are not getting
laughs because you can't roar every line
in a top ten list yeah you can't what
would that be meant that be insanity I
mean you wouldn't get to watch it if it
was that hilarious that every time they
say the next one you laughed you know so
the pacing of it Jerry Seinfeld comes
out and says his line and it's kind of
here huh you know like whoever was you
know I forget which ones had the worst
lines but it's not that their lines were
bad it's just that when they're all
stacked up like that they can't all be
winners who do you think had the best
line of that top set I don't remember
probably Julia Louie Dreyfus because she
kills it everywhere Bruce she doesn't
show up and not kill it lately really
yeah on her TV shows movies and like
she's amazing on veep like there's
hardly ever a funnier female performance
in the history of anything than her on
beep really yeah and she's already got
you know ten years of Seinfeld under her
belt where she was also amazing and and
then she on award shows she always does
something cool or funny and she gets she
ropes in the other people like she's
roped in Sarah Silverman and Amy Poehler
and Tina Fey into Lake and they wrote
they wrote both as well it's like a it's
a two-way rope but with all four of
those women they're all four women that
like when they show up to something like
that they'll have a mustache on when it
cuts to them or they'll make a mad face
when they lose instead of trying to be
gracious yeah and in the case of Julia
Louie Dreyfus on that last guess it must
have been was it the Emmys uh-uh Bryan
Cranston she talked about him in her
acceptance speech and how he's not he
wasn't that great of a kisser when she
kissed him on Seinfeld and then and then
later in the show when he won he went
over and just planted one on her yeah
and it was planned but it was so
perfectly set up because she burned him
and then he comes over and just makes
out with her you know just really lays
went on her and I think the gag was
after he stopped kissing her she's still
like kind of shrug like now still no
good whatever but you know like I love
her anyway I didn't come here to talk
about no but you're Julia Louie Dreyfus
the whole time I know but I like you're
inside all next I would never I never
watched veep but just watching so I was
like I I feel like there's this uh this
almost curse of like of the this sign
what next project after sign
feld and everyone does the mean you just
like like you're like uh ever you're
still there George or you're still
watching we call it yeah well she had a
you know a rebound show she was on the
new adventures of old Christine like
this which was okay but it was like you
know I think the move to single camera
is really good for her because she's so
brilliant and so subtle that you know
you don't need a studio audience sitting
there laughing at every little thing
like she'll have little like she can
just turn on a dime and do the funniest
things yeah the thing about veep is for
some it might not be for some people
because everyone is so ugly to each
other on it like the people everyone is
really mean which i think is probably
what politics is really like you know
what we're missing out on you know is
that the President the Vice President
price and around saying those [ __ ]
over it where you know I mean they're
swearing yeah you know and its really
funny patent was on a few episodes I
don't know if his uh if he's gonna
continue but Patton Oswalt was a Patton
Oswalt why is your device going off
let's no look and see what it is let's
find out what it is uh probably before
we talk about how great oh joey diaz is
on periscope me with the neighborhood
cats these periscoping right now he's
periscoping right now see if i can come
here smokey show the camera people
comedians are just gonna favor
beautifully put a pork chop out this huh
give him some [ __ ] they're just gonna
periscope everything they do oh yeah
[ __ ] Joey Diaz that's unprecedented
access to like somebody like Joey da you
know he does that people can just watch
him do things that he does and talk talk
to them my favorite thing he does is 6a
me always smokes a joint on periscope on
periscope 6am god bless him and he just
sits on his porch smokes a joint and
then talks about something usually that
that you know is like Joey has two types
of stories he has stories that are like
that are [ __ ] like so big like you
got to be talking about that on stage
and then he's got the ones that he
doesn't know
that like you gotta hear him tell and
listen he doesn't know there's a joke in
it like he told me a story about getting
attacked by a dog when he was a kid he's
like he was like Burt you have no idea
how many times I got attacked by dogs
when I got to this country I said when
he goes I don't know the dogs in this
country i think i heard him say that too
because I gotta take but I got attacked
by six dogs my first month I said really
goes yeah the last one walked past me
and then came back to bite walk past me
get back yeah oh god damn it he get
makes me laugh so [ __ ] hard he's good
stuff he's good man he's had a lot of
life yeah he's lived yeah he really
genuinely had he's like a great example
of like you know that they're there are
always a chance for a second act you
know like Jay London was my example of
that really what's he doing now though I
don't know but yeah see Joey's is really
working out periscope and playing with
cats Jay London isn't doing that you
don't have that technology or friendly
animals oh I should smoke I can smoke on
camera because that's what I don't smoke
but if you brought your marijuana can
smoke a slider everything overkill yeah
there's a lot right there ah so we could
talk about this after if you want but I
was I was disappointed when you've got
you know you're going out on a bunch
more roller coasters and rides and stuff
and you know you I got a list of dates
saying Doug can you go to go do this
with me in any of these dates yeah and
I'm already all booked up there was
nothing I could make happen what how
they said you're gonna get some more
date soon lower yeah we're doing six and
then another six yeah so the second six
when does it start i want to try to
leave a hole open I don't know I don't
know I tell you what we should do that
I'd to find out I want to go to the new
ride and Cara wins I just did it I i was
on the very first time the public got to
ride it I was on the very first ride are
you sure yeah I was in I was in town and
I was in Charlotte and I tweeted about
you know being in Charlotte yeah
somebody from carowinds like reached out
and said hey do you know while you're
here do you want to come on the new
rollercoaster I'm like yeah opens Friday
and there
first they wanted me to come to press
day but I couldn't go to that yeah so
then they're like but you can come
friday and you know a guy just met me
and walked me in and took me to the ride
and then the interesting thing about it
was the day the ride debuted they
delayed the first ride for like two
hours because the temperature has to get
to a certain it can it can't be a
certain amount of coal it was a cold day
for the brick for the for the thing that
put the air thing I guess so or also
just Public Safety like face burn or
whatever no its you been on a lot of
roller coasters on a really cold day
i've been i've been tend not to operate
right yeah no no I've been on a lot of
roller coasters on cold days I've mostly
on the show in the summer but I have
been on cold days and I know that one
time it was an air compression take off
and the air wasn't it was too cold and
wasn't working this is sting I think
that's what it is now this was something
about how they just they just can't run
it because it's like you're moving so
fast is probably physically dangerous or
something like I really they literally
waited for the temperature to become a
59 or 60 or so there was some number
they were waiting for it to hit and we
literally stood you know I went on some
other rides while I was waiting but what
other rides can work but this one can't
exactly what I'm saying this is a
particular ride they can't run it when
it's too cold for some reason what's the
rod is and it was unseasonable cold the
place is only open in the summer yeah
you know the day they open should have
been a nice beautiful day but it just
you know was what must it have been it
must have been in May so what's right is
the ride how long like uh what's it
called again do you know I don't know
because that cuz the number in the title
it's like fury 240 or something like
that whatever the number is that's how
long the ride takes and how long the
first drop it how high the first drop is
0 is in the name of the ride oh it must
be fury 240 or something like that's not
fury 420 I know that would be all over
that its fury 240 I think and they you
know and they didn't call it just fury
they added the number
into the kid that was walking me around
I don't know how much he knows but his
theory may have was that you know that
Brad Pitt movie fury about the tank I'm
sort of those bad timing that kind of
ruined the word fury oh yeah yeah I want
throat for a minute or two you yeah that
does a great [ __ ] movie though yeah
and that's but carowinds is one of those
parks where a lot of the rides have just
let they have kind of funky names
because they used to be it used to be
owned by Paramount all the rides used to
be like top gun and you know they used
to be named after movies and stuff so
whatever read the ad is narrow size them
one of my favorite rides in the
country's at karen's what's that called
the intimidator which one is that it's
the one with the NASCAR themed one were
you it's it's uh it is the it's the best
page 1 of the two best rods in the
country in my opinion same designer for
both of them he did uh what was the name
of heated Diamondback at out of Queens
Queens at Kings Island Diamondback at
Kings Island and he did the Intimidator
at Carowinds I think it's the
Intimidator and it's it's a based on a
Dale Earnhardt juniors car and it's got
barber shop top seats just a lap band
and your feet dangle it's the best free
fall both of those are the best two rods
I've ever ridden cuz Diamondback a thing
comes down and holds you lap in that's
yes that's it that's it and that's what
makes that ride [ __ ] amazing yeah but
if they also the same thing happen with
is on the Intimidator the Intimidator I
think it's the Intimidator but it's a
NASCAR themed ride it's after Dale
Earnhardt jr. Dale Earnhardt the who was
the Intimidator I wouldn't even dare to
correct you either way yeah but um I
don't know enough about Dale but yeah
it's uh those are my favorite rods we
eat is making me tear up really yeah
sometimes I'm my you know I'm allergic
to you know to weed to grass and you
know i have like regular regular you
know all the typical allergies so some
strains we'd all like take a big hit and
then next thing you know i'll just
really like sniffling in my eyes will
get watery and you know but I power
through it was cuz you know I'm allergic
to be like being high
yeah I have uh I want to say Hodgkin's
but that's not what it is what's it
called when you have real allergic to
gluten it's called SAR sack star sack
disease again I you know could be called
Dale SAR sacks or all i know so the
rides fun though it's super fun like a
you know really great drop at the
beginning and then just you know I got
to go on a couple times and then just a
lot of you know a lot of business for
like he's over on the lift is uh you
know um probably minute of the 240 you
know and then you fly around for a
minute and 40 seconds oh yeah I guess
they incorporate that they do they
always [ __ ] minute that's always part
of it but that's fun to that they have
so many now that just shoot out of the
station without the clickity-clackity
clickity-clackity I was on Tulsa word
for that what do they call it just uh
it's I don't know the names of inertia a
drop coaster no no no for when they just
shoot you out of the station oh that's
called I'm [ __ ] know this yeah you do
a hydraulic report propulsion or
something no it's got there's a name for
it there's there's a bunch of different
kinds there's kinds of like the magnetic
ones where you just keep going by the
magnets so it shoots you you know that
one mm-hmm they got that one out at and
[ __ ] Texas at six flags you know like
california screamin at california
adventure here in LA I've never been to
California Adventure in LA oh [ __ ] well
they just you just sit at the station
and light goes being you know like a
like a roadster like a race and then the
when it gets to green it just shoots out
I did top thrill dragster which is the
same guy that's a good but that one
that's much hairier that you know the
disney one is still disney so those
scary as it gets is just a big loop but
but that that top thrill dragster that
thing's [ __ ] up you know i got is a
good way hop right no you've never seen
that video uh the very first pilot we
did for birthday calm how do you get
stuck at the top where you too fat nope
it was cold and this should i run it and
we were waiting too long they were
waiting too long so that they build up
the air and uh and when we were waiting
it was just slowly start
hang out and it's cold so there's not a
lot of it so we take off and we've got
like maybe eight people in the coaster
and we get up to the top the first time
we get up to the top and it just doesn't
make it over and doesn't roll back and I
at all oh I know it's definitely uh
supposed to happen that's a bad thing
exactly what I'm thinking yeah talking
the microphone by the way but I thought
you were gonna talk a lot of times and I
was gonna take another hit I'll take
another hit and i'll tell you about tell
us so we go back it rolls back and
they've got to now like basically redo
the entire ride bring us back to the
thing and then we do it again and it
goes up to the top and it [ __ ] hits
the top and it stops right at the
[ __ ] top and i'm like [ __ ] this and I
start shaking uncontrollably like going
and and thinking and I think it'll row
forward and it rolls back again it just
goes I brought us back so we go back
into the station and I'm like
[ __ ] and they're like we'll get
it this time I'm like no you didn't get
out no we've not gotten out of the ride
once here's the world you get after
after two failed attempts and wood on
that second one you were going no no I'm
losing my [ __ ] money why'd you go a
third time cuz i doing a [ __ ] TV show
and so did all this get into the TV show
all this gets into the TV show and then
the roller coaster makers in that
particular park weren't embarrassed
they're not embarrassed because they
have a story that's legendary that adds
thrills of the rod and that is the time
the coaster got stuck and they couldn't
rock it back and forth and what has to
happen is they have to call a guy who
has to come out and drive and the only
one guy knows how to do it but wait wait
here this there's only one guy certified
to do this comes out and he's gotta walk
up the 420 feet on the on this catwalk
on this ladder type thing all the way
the top and all he does is push it but
he's the only guy certified that can go
up and piss it's a dangerous climb the
danger he knows the roller coaster he
knows these deep drives
pels the coaster every day and check
that all strong guy I don't know I
didn't meet the guy but there to brian
it you know i mean to push the whole
thing and get it going again literally
they say he just puts his foot on it and
kicks it I'm not even [ __ ] around and
then I think he waits for the next time
but so they're telling me this and they
go yeah there's certain there's a
certain [ __ ] hit that if you get up
there it gets stuck and it won't move
back and forth you need someone to come
up and kick it will call the guy and
everyone's like oh I'm pray to God like
last people were stuff like 30 minutes
up top there and [ __ ] 400 live you
know how close you should have a cot
right there at the yeah so we do it the
third time in the third time we went up
and over and we did it but man that
rollback was scary a [ __ ] I literally
was like freaking out yeah cuz there's
so many rides where they make you go
backwards on purpose and stuff where you
go back through it backwards you know so
you use that sensation and it's
enjoyable but you never want it when
it's blot not part of the ride oh you
know like the jurassic park ride at
Universal I was on it with the fun bunch
I think Scott Aukerman and BJ Porter and
probably their ladies at the time maybe
cool up but we're sitting there in it on
the part where it goes up to you know to
the top two then go to fall and go back
and you know it's kind of a further for
people who might not know what it is cuz
you've been on it I don't know I'm sure
I've I don't know it's amazing that
you've been on all these ice ever done
and you've never done the ones that you
live right by no I've never done the
ones i live by okay so what's the
furthest way one you've done Oh Germany
no probably we haven't done Europe
probably like why okay you got roller
coasters in Y or you did some sort
others thrill thing water parks a really
hairy slide Mexico the ones in Mexico
were kind of sketchy right cuz you're
like because you're literally you're
thinking who what's the legal system of
how you find out if this is safe or not
yeah but uh Mexico and then I think
that's as far as I went and then I've
done them all over the country but I I
was out at Magic Mountain for like a
whole summer for like three months I
worked there every day with jason nash
and uh and I he's got a new show coming
on country music television CMT yeah
what is it wait sorry not Jason and
thinking of josh Josh wolf why is Jason
NASA Josh wolf the same to me very
similar but [ __ ] but I but why I've said
this a number of times my favorite part
we wrote I had to ride like every
coaster every single day it was a game
show on a roller coaster so the game
show happened on the roller coaster was
called scream if you know the answer it
was really funny but no one watched it
was there anyone ride there and I'm
still going to tell my Jurassic Park
story is there anyone ride there that
you know you got you got really sick of
or that you never really enjoyed having
to do it repeatedly yes of what's the
one that's the African name the one that
you they lean you forward yes I hate
that right that right and I hate the
versions of that I don't like I don't
like that feeling of being held from
underneath on my chest I don't either
and and having to lay like that for the
entire ride like there's moments of it
where you can kind of forget that you're
you know like like the one at they have
one of those at Carowinds yeah and that
one's a little bit more fun than the one
out here I I do I still don't like the
feeling of it I don't like it either
it's like you're on a stretcher upside
down or something that's not it really
feel like you're flying and doesn't feel
you're flying and when you're waiting
and [ __ ] like there's coaster in
front of you you're waiting in the back
here and and I got stuck in that for
[ __ ] 45 minutes oh I guess sucking up
for 45 minutes to the [ __ ] ride and I
had a it's what it literally is like of
one of the times i know that i had a
definite panic attack so I was on a ride
and that's like niche that's that's
horrible forced planking yep involuntary
blanket I was on a ride at busch gardens
and in richmond virginia Oh Gavin I've
only been to the one in Tampa I'm not
rich manage whatever it is it's in
Virginia it's actually one of the most
beautiful parks in the country I'm not
even joking it is so gorgeous the one in
Virginia yeah nice Gordon that are my
two favorite parks visually I like that
Eagle ride at Dollywood Oh Darla coaster
Dollywood
[ __ ] fantastic i love you know it's
not just fantastic it's religious yes
it's patriotic yeah it's weird it is
weird how religious and patriotic it and
a pig on a spit you know like we're
gonna cook a pig in front of you like
Disneyland would never air maybe they
wanted a luau but it is small town
pigeon but it was very yeah well them
and there's parts of it like you've gone
on that [ __ ] mind train ride thing
that's like the cheapest oldest
shittiest ride in the history of
anything that they just still have open
and there's no line to go on it yeah
it's just so dumb so bad it's like you
cuz you could just see I see this at
amusement parks all over the country the
the just the knockoffs of Disney rides
yeah I you know they just do shitty
versions of Disney rides and just sort
of get away with it's like a lot of
parks or I would I I love when there's a
great ride and it's all over the place
and you're like like I said like the
Intimidator or Diamondback when you see
in a couple you oh um I know that ride I
can't wait to hit that or you know the
one in Jersey and topped old rags are
very similar odds but um but yeah I hate
when you find a ride you're like oh [ __ ]
this is there's nothing special to this
like I'm not gonna [ __ ] on the rides but
like there's some that happen it I think
it's Universal that you that you like
yeah I get it like I don't need I don't
really think that the other coaster
that's going simultaneously is really
gonna hit I understand we'll get close
but the fear of that doesn't lose me and
then there's some there's some there's
some actual things that I'm tired of
like certain applications of a coaster
like the Immelman loop is everywhere
it's like it's it's it's a fine fighter
pilot maximal men came up with this
maneuver and it's you ride it in the
coast rich when you go like this and
kind of dive and turn around upside down
them do a loop and I'm like enough about
the Immelman loops I just give me
[ __ ] a great free fall and then I
want some badass like just [ __ ] dive
into the woods I forget which ride has
it but I was on one recently where it's
just got every every single possible
permutation
you know the physical things you can you
know kind of like Batman and Riddler and
those those you're like they they're
really they put them in a smaller space
and just have lots of crazy different
things that happen in a short space and
this one that I was on had all this
great stuff happened I wish I can all
right it was the names are so hard to
keep straight I know cuz they never
really say anything about the ride you
asked me about a ride at Disneyland I
can tell you exactly what it's called
and what happens on it you know I mean
every other goddamn amusement park just
named [ __ ] so arbitrarily it's like it's
like names for weed yeah I should do a
bit is this a name for weed or a roller
coaster and just name off a bunch of it
oh I bet you can find a ton absolutely
there's got a bizarro I mean there's
ones for both so I'm on Jurassic Park
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeahs finishes
tour with some friends but I don't know
if that makes it better or worse you
know when these things happen if your
friends are sitting there cuz you know
you have people commiserate with but you
also you know if you're there by
yourself you know just kind of get
through it without being so upset I
don't know so it's going up it's going
up and then all of a sudden it just goes
good gun and goes back a notch you know
and then it waits a beat and then it
goes good gun like it's like trying to
go up and just falling back this one so
it's not like it's gonna it's not
falling all the way back yeah but it's
giving you this motion like you're about
to fall all the way back and it must
have done it 50 or 70 times before they
got us out of there are you [ __ ]
serious single when is this gonna stop
yeah it's making me crazy and it feels
scary because it's not supposed to drop
backwards at all yeah oh I the first
panic attack i had i was gonna say is in
richmond virginia and we were in that
ride that's a lot like it's the one
where they tits it's the same ride
that's also in Busch Gardens Tampa and
they take you up you're the thing and
then they hold you over the ledge and
they wait wait wait and then you stand
out of the ride starts I love that I
love that I love that I love that ride
and I'm excited to ride it
do it and we get pulled out into the
state like right outside the station and
they're having a problem with that car
and they got to fix it and I'm fine I'm
fine sitting in the Sun for a minute i'm
right next to a kid and the kid just
leans over he goes hey man you think you
could get out if you needed to and I was
like what do you think you get out of
this harness if you needed to and I was
like and all the sudden I realized I
can't [ __ ] move and I was like I'm in
a panic attack and I'm like [ __ ]
what's why this kid do this to me and
I'm losing my [ __ ] and the kid by the
way is sliding his arm out like this and
then sliding his arm out cuz he can fit
right I can't move and I'm just [ __ ]
panicking and I literally start I have a
microphone I'm like okay guys you need
get me the [ __ ] out of here like right
now right now so that is nothing
compared to getting stuck to the one
stuck in the one out at Magic Mountain
where I'm facing down and though and
there's the woman that runs it is a more
like a Harley type looking woman like
just like a gruff woman show you her
name's Judy I'm sure short hair like
overalls and she just is like oh you
just really no no nonsense woman
insulted all Judy's she comes over as
she goes she goes uh alright guys gonna
be about 45 minutes and I'm like and I I
go I'm I don't know any of this make
sense but I go I'm gonna need to get out
right now can you just undo mine cuz i
can't sit like this for 45 minutes cuz
now i'm thinking of that kid going do
you know if you wanted to and I start
freaking out and I'm like I no no no I
need to get out like right now I need to
get out like right now and she's like
listen she gets out of my level she
looks at me she goes the guy that needs
to fix this is at home he's coming out
from his house to fix this you're gonna
be fine and I go Judy I'm having a panic
attack she sits on the ground underneath
me and hold my hand underneath in the
ride is it for 45 minutes I just [ __ ]
hell her hand she's like breathe breathe
and I was like okay okay I can't believe
you still that you're the guy that's
going around doing this kind of stuff on
camera when you have all these incidents
I've arrived in direct honest now I'm
shaking back saying that I want to go
with you to one of these things Oh Jim
Norton you freak it out next to me would
freak me out uh yeah I guess or baby I'd
laugh so hard that I die laughing yeah
you
it's it's it's gonna be a fun season
then we do the third act fourth actor
like big events so we're doing like
greasy pole out in Gloucester
Massachusetts and like the the hooligan
race and so it should be a fun see it's
a fun show to do during the summer hey
do you want to go I do but I brought I
brought my book with me with all my
dates in it because we do it for the
July I want to do something I made plans
man what do you got on fourth of July is
it in Denver no damn it it's in Jersey
oh I'll tell you what oh I that's the
things I was probably one of the dates
they sent me and I know I can't because
because all that everything you've got
so far as like July and then august i
think our little into august maybe yeah
John uh yeah and I'm already pretty
booked up you know what also just a
proximity problems like what part of the
country will be in and stuff you know
because you're all over the place with
these things yeah it's two weeks on two
weeks off it's all only golf and then
we're doing like three two weeks I think
but I'll find out the next schedule and
i'll [ __ ] I'll get it to you
beforehand so you can do something we'll
do a ride you want to do yeah yeah I i I
just I love amusement parks and I it's
one of my things that I I you know build
into my travel a lot I even have kind of
a mo with it because I'll if I'm working
a club on a weekend that has a park I'll
get up super early on saturday morning
and just do you know take all the steps
that are needed to be ready to go run to
the biggest coaster the second the gates
open really you know in some places will
have an early bird thing or if you pay
more you get in an hour early whatever
it takes I just want to get in there
early get on the best ride right away
riding it ride it until a line starts to
build yeah you know just keep getting
back on it good exercise a lot of these
places because you got a [ __ ] walk a
mile to get back on Dollywood's all up
yeah oh yeah it's brutal so we was
crowded when I went to Dollywood so we
didn't get any that much action but like
Dollywood the whole time I was like I'm
coming back here because it's too
crowded today but I love this [ __ ] so
we
that with dolly when we went there they
have a whole a theater inside the park
and the marquee says I'm pretty sure all
the time a marquee name is like playing
in there yup three shows that day that
people could just go in and watch and
it's like huge names and country I told
my wife I said when we go back back down
to Atlanta I want to take all the girls
over Dollywood I go you'll [ __ ] love
it and lands like dolly would trust me
[ __ ] what about six flags I was like
[ __ ] it Dollywood you can go there's Six
Flags everywhere there's only one
Dollywood and the [ __ ] to do in pigeon
forge also they've got that Azure balls
i'm pretty sure i'm going to pigeon
forge this year but yeah i think i saw
that on the list pigeon forge and we're
doing like David's or balls they have
[ __ ] bungee they have all the thrills
they have the controlled descent
everything I'm pigeon forge is it's a
great town I love it whoa whoa whoa Doug
have I talked to you about audible com
okay clearly this is an ad and I just
inserted in the middle but I thought I
could slide it in and you wouldn't
notice autocom is our sponsor they have
more than 180,000 audiobooks and spoken
word audio products get a free audiobook
of your choice at www casscom backslash
Burt cast get you know what I get I get
the war of art by steven pressfield get
that you'll [ __ ] love it all right
back to the show controlled descent is
just when they drop you yeah it's like
everyone that's something that I I enjoy
it when I do it my favorite thing about
it is putting a coin on my knee because
the first jostle makes it get fall off
your knee but then it falls at the same
rate you do so it's just floating as you
fall best rides um easily i think the
most thrilling rides in the country and
i don't know if anyone agrees with me on
this are the three roller coasters at
the top of the stratosphere ah just
because they're the top of stratosphere
it just heightens it it's you're so high
that thing where you're in those chairs
and the claw goes out and they turn they
spin I did that and felt regret the
entire time the one where you're in the
roller coaster just sort of goes around
I don't know it was that great and then
the one with a dangle you I'll just put
you out there near the front seat it's
pretty intense like really intense dude
those rides doing those rides scared me
off of bungee jumping off of the
stratosphere and if I had just bought
the bungee jump thing first I would have
just done it yeah but those other things
may be so scared about stratosphere when
you look at it from when you're on the
top of it and when you're on the ground
it doesn't look thick enough to have one
room in it let alone be an entire hotel
exactly such a skinny looking building
it's like it's like buck in the
Washington Monument be a hotel inside I
don't think so i think it's just a
staircase yeah so and when you're on top
of it it's the top part is like a [ __ ]
you know it's big [ __ ] top up there so
you can't you're just the view is just
like yeah your day it's like you're
dangling no matter where you are up
there oh we did them in a thunderstorm
there's I do also like that the palms
that that outdoor bar upstairs a ghost
bar oh yeah he's so glass floor yeah
with the glass floor and like you know
drives my friends crazy but I stomp on
that thing and they'll just go what are
you doing yeah I'm stomping on a thing
that if it could possibly break this
place would be [ __ ] my family would
own this place my family's gonna owe
this [ __ ] place next time I go there
make a vine of that oh yeah I the
stratosphere we're up there in a
thunderstorm and hail started coming in
and I mean that weather just changes
instantly at the stratosphere like cuz
it's so high up but one weather comes
through yes it's so windy out there in
the desert and we when we did the sky
today we did describe the winds have to
be under 35 miles per hour cuz you if
not you start blowing into the buildings
and it was just and then the way it does
they have a wind meter that reads the
win if it ever hits 35 miles an hour you
gotta wait 15 minutes and if it doesn't
do it 50 minutes taking up in the ride
and then we just watch it and all said
it's like 45 45 and I'm just going and
we're just waiting and I'm thinking guys
[ __ ] that like let's do it tomorrow when
the winds at
15 and we know it because I'm gonna jump
and then I'm a win's gonna come through
and push me into the building that was a
terrifying I open that ride I was the
first person to do it that was a [ __ ]
I was the first person first timers Club
yeah it's a I did that and scoots me
it's really neat it really is being the
first group of people to ride it it's
it's I mean it so everyone close to the
first time you ride it is but it's just
funny it's just a weird kind of pride
you get it's like a similar product is
Uma people who really give a [ __ ] about
their you know their team winning a game
you know yeah you know it's like you've
done nothing special just you justyou
were just there experienced it but you
were first you won you know yeah it's uh
it's all it's great that as human beings
we can get excited about [ __ ] and I'll
tell you something about it music parks
it always blows me away what I can't go
anywhere now without occasional picture
being taken or someone just yelling at
me super high me or whatever yeah and
amusement parks are just still there
their wholesome America like nobody says
[ __ ] to me sometimes I have a hat and
sunglasses and that that helps yeah but
generally nobody says a word to me all
day long maybe one little stoner kid
I'll come up and say hey man you Doug
Benson or whatever but it's the lead I
get the least bothered there that of
anywhere yeah it's really interesting I
mean probably not notice it you're
totally right is I when I by the end of
the second season of birth conquer
anyone that worked at a theme park was
like was like they definitely knew who I
was because everyone knew that that was
the roller coaster show and then like
the next year I went whew i was doing
something for something that I has ended
up to cedar point and these are all the
kids that I mean every day were on this
they definitely watch show and no one no
one said anything to me and there I same
thing happen at Kings Island they kind
of no one said anything and then I get
off the ride I got off Diamondback and
one of the kids cuz hey man we know you
are it's like oh cool he was like uh you
want to come back man any seat you want
and I was like really he's a gay it was
like a back left corner like that's my
favorite [ __ ] seat on that ride the
back of a coaster in my opinion on a
free fall on a drop is better than the
front
hands down every [ __ ] time it's it's
a better feeling yeah it's a better
feeling but being in front is again I'm
in front that's exciting yeah you know
that you're at you know like that people
see that people you know there's that
extra line to get in the front cars and
a lot of roller coasters that they allow
you know I I hate places where they're
really strict about you have to go here
like if somebody wants to be in a
certain part of the coaster let them
hang back for as long as it takes yeah
you know and then and then get to do it
nobody what are your feelings the best
the back is pretty that's what I'll if I
get to go on coaster twice i try to the
front and the back and you know
sometimes you're in the middle sometimes
it happens and and you know what you're
still flying around Oh a roller coaster
I'm you know in the back every time I
get one I literally will wait my time in
line and be like no no over there but do
you you say you don't for fun also try
the front you just like the back so much
that you'll just keep your cell always
in the back I do it twice i'll do the
front and the back but if i do it once
it's always the back except on rides
like like like the one we were talking
about that drop coaster in Busch Gardens
I love the front because when you dangle
it like 290s 210 feet when you dangle
there and you're looking down you want
that visual it's going one in those
vegas rides you know what the rides I
think all danglers the front rows the
best because there's there's limited
view in every other row because you got
you got people in front of you yeah you
know but there's not not just heads like
their whole thing is in front of you but
when on those uh it's like it's a
potential motion coasters like where
they are kinetic motion coasters where
they take you up to the top 310 feet and
then you drop that drop in the back you
feel like you're getting pulled off a
boat with an anchor tied to your foot
like it's like just like don't like you
get pulled over and the free-falls also
i I'd argue 30 feet longer than the guy
in the front who goes over the top and
then he's leaning leaning leaning and
you gotta wait for the back to unhook
before you drop it cuts some of the
freefall the freefall is what I love the
most the best rock but if you in the
back of that too though you do get a you
know you do get that sort of extra whip
that the whole tray that the whole thing
pulling you over that edge makes out you
know you get more a stronger sensation
but you're right that the front is you
got to get
you got to get that view the beast in
the wooden roller coaster of the beast
wooden roller coasters I have a
love-hate relationship with because so
many of them just beat the [ __ ] out of
you it's not worth the thrills that it's
not as thrilling as a you know they
can't they can't go is high they can't
have I mean now I guess there's one that
has a loop a wooden coaster with a loose
shut the [ __ ] up I think so yeah are you
see I think so no wooden coasters
literally you get like the [ __ ]
junior sale traumatic brain injury if
you do them too much I'm not even
[ __ ] around like I had I had one of
the experts out it uh I want to say it's
Noah's Ark one of the rod not Noah's Ark
it's one out in the dells and he was
like I one of my kids do this too much I
was like serious he's like yeah he's
like you know you get very limited the
best rides I've been dying to say to you
for like the past 10 minutes the best
rides ever in my opinion that blow me
away you just said stratosphere already
nope nope I forgot about this ride oh
god the ones in Universal that like the
spider-man rod where it's all visual and
they blow fire and children e yeah I
fought and they and they just skate they
keep doing similar variations like the
Transformers is very similar prints by
the Transformers ride at Universal
Studios is a million times more
entertaining than any Transformers movie
cartoon or anything easily it's really
great but that's how I feel about I
think other than maybe like Empire
Strikes Back I think Star Tours is the
best Star Wars really yeah it's really
well done it's really well done it's a
and it was start or start out great and
then they you know changed it changed it
and redid everything and it's still
great like both you know I kind of I'm
nostalgic for the old ride because you
know used to be your captain or whatever
was a robot voice bye peewee Herman oh
and I you know always a huge pee-wee
Herman fan so what discipline that first
time we went on it and he's like oh no
we're kinda tractor beam you know we
were like so delighted that it was
pee-wee Herman being a robot on the Star
Wars thing
yeah and then they redid it and now
c-3po is the you know they they booted
that dude spider the robot I did we did
an episode at Universal for trip flip
and then they say basically they gave us
the park for the morning and they're
like no one's there you can write
whatever the [ __ ] you want and so I
literally had no expectation for
spidermen it's neat like it's really
like like you know doesn't he sling his
web and grab the car and then pull it it
really feels like you just suddenly got
yet feels like you really well done oh
it's really well done and I all I
thought was how about getting low
getting like [ __ ] like Top Thrill
Dragster and adding that element of the
screen I'm you can take that so far that
it just seems like that's where the
future of well that's a you've been on
the wonderful world of harry potter ride
uh yes i have to it because we did we
did a that's the one where it's like
you're in like a dune buggy like how to
Mansion at Disneyland but you go through
oh yeah they have that they have actual
footage of all the actors from the movie
yeah and but it's a combination of
actually throwing you around and then
also similar to transformers yeah like
but it's to me but then there's a
physical thing at the end like a dragon
or something that's actually huge in the
room yeah and not you know not film in
it and you play Quidditch for a while
yeah you know and you feel like you're
flying around it's that ride to me is
that was the first time because now
probably transformer spider-man whatever
but that one really felt to me like this
is using all the elements all the right
elements in one ride oh and it's really
really fun the free fall on spider-man
when you when you fall off the building
Peter Parker's got to save you what
spider-man's gonna save you that free
fall I know I'm not dropping I know that
by [ __ ] body works I lost my stomach
I was like yeah ice cream at a what
stinks is we can't cover any of those
rides on television properly because
that way you'd never be able to do it
right and but those are the greatest
goddamn rods man no it would almost give
it a cheese factor and make it not look
good to see people watching a screen and
screaming and they're not moving
or whatever you know like it just blows
it it stinks because that those rides
redefined and they got the one I think
at Disney's Raiders of the Ark raiders
of the lost ark it's similar a little
bit you know but uh those rides blow me
away that's another thing star tours has
multiple situations so anytime you go on
and you're going to see something
different yeah you know this the story
goes off the story goes off in different
ways they go to different star wars
lands and you know it's still always an
adventure about getting in this this
little kind of like tourists speeder
that's being operated by c-3po and then
getting caught up in some sort of bad
situation yeah and then and then making
it back to the station you know yeah
it's but it's a man I love rides I ride
so much go back and this summer because
one of the coolest parts of the show is
like I did I did Superman out in in
magic mountain with Warren Sapp & warren
sapp got done and he was like and he was
like and who's it's so unwarranted I say
that I hope if he's listening and I know
he's not but like it was very unborn
sighs just taking pictures with a
warrant he was take a picture with
everybody and he was like because he was
like a kid again he goes he loves rides
and so like normally he's like a stoic
kind of don't bother me kind of guy but
he's like taking pictures with the group
he's holding people up taking pic it was
[ __ ] awesome and then he goes he's
the sense to me is like man I just wish
I could ride more of these rides and I
go what do you mean wish I go Warren we
have the keys to every [ __ ] ride cuz
the park's closed alright what do you
mean I go over the guy go hey guys
Warren would like to ride it the rods
and they're like of course go let's go
and this guy I just goes with him and
opens every ride turns it on and lets
him ride it so we're shooting like
pickups and Warren Sapp is riding every
[ __ ] coaster in the park just by
himself ah it was that's the greatest
part is that getting the park to
yourself oh yeah anything special you
know like that's what I was going to say
about cedar point is one time i went
there and i took a friend of mine and I
just you know took the hit just a bit
the bullet and paid you you basically
higher they just have people there that
you hire and you get them for eight
hours the
and the rules are they get to have a
one-hour break to eat again a one-hour
lunch break at some point where they
leave you alone for an hour which is
probably a good thing yeah everybody
concerned and you can get there when the
park opens and stay till close you know
state like eight you get it for eight
hours for you know a certain price it's
expensive and then uh they take you to
the front of any ride you want to go on
the only rule is you can't uh you can't
go multiple times on anything you can't
even just walk off and go right back on
you gotta go to a different ride okay
but she takes you there and you go right
to the front of line got [ __ ] 23 and
you I can't get over now I've been twice
where I've been with somebody from the
park taking me around yeah at one time
they Duvall adhered another time I paid
for it but both times I just couldn't
get over how excited I was that any
questions that popped into my head about
the [ __ ] Park I could just ask
somebody standing right there you know
you don't have to go find somebody or
ask the person as they're letting you
onto the ride you know you got a person
to just that you know and they often
they're like sometimes out answer a lot
of questions with I don't know but they
also know a lot of stuff about it and
and whether they know stuff about it or
not there's when you talk to amusement
park employees they've all got stories
and they've all got you know theories
and opinions yeah you know and it's all
it's all really interesting because
because there are so many different
kinds of rides and people and and
reactions to them you know like a cedar
point I might I mean no questions asked
millennium force is probably the best
really great it's probably the best I
got [ __ ] tore up by bugs though and I
was at that really sparked the last time
because i didn't i didn't think to put
on bug spray I know oh yeah I guess
doing cuz it's cuz it's on the water
there and it's the circuit I'm nasty
it's really natty and buggy yeah um but
that rides amazing skyhawk isn't
millennium force another one where
that's just the latter far that's it
just lap bar 310 feet up and then
[ __ ] a droplet I looked it up just
because I was being such an idiot about
fury 240 because obviously 240 is
the isn't any kind of record its fury
325 the drop 325 feet and the ride is
three minutes and 25 seconds long oh
[ __ ] that's gonna be good yeah holy [ __ ]
really it was on man is it a lap belt or
is it shoulder I think it's shoulder
because you you really [ __ ] fly
around to do a lot of stuff that was one
thing I was going to say earlier than we
got sidetracked I thing is that there's
one ride where you do everything and
then at the end they just it you're just
you're going straight and then it curves
and you're upside down for a bit and it
goes all the way back around and it
keeps going straight so you're just like
a pig on a moving spit just turning over
to you have this sensation of being
absolutely you know upside down not like
when you're in a loop when you can just
feel that you're being pushed into your
seat you're upside down like oh I will
fall the [ __ ] out of this think it's are
emptying yeah right now it's not a whole
ride of it like when you're laying down
you know I mean yeah so it's a thrill
but it's quick you know like it yeah
it's at the end of a great ride I can't
think of which ride it was if you know
calling the number is 100 I love I love
a bizarro out in uh in New England I
love the end of bizarro those [ __ ]
tight loops right before you go into the
first race first met for as many roller
coasters I've been on in parks I've been
to there's still so many Oh left for me
to do like um I keep hearing new names
of music parks like cause like you know
I've just been going on the model of
like if there isn't a six flags around
what it what is you know what's going to
be around probably some little broke
dick thing but there's a lot of big
independent parks and parks that are
kind of owned by one company but they
all the parks of different names you
don't really know yet which way was the
company's gardens yeah what's with that
I bet they're a terrible name yeah it's
a it is elated either we were named yeah
and the last time I was in Denver was
the was am a 10 for Mother's Day and I
was excited to be there because I was
going to go [ __ ] up some roller coasters
over at elitch and it was uh goddamn
snowing are you serious yeah yeah they
and people in Denver say that like for
the last few years a winter's gone well
into well into may really like snowing
in May pretty
pretty consistently for the last few
years oh you know what ride we're doing
and [ __ ] Denver is up in I think it's
uh pending Glenwood caverns it's a
[ __ ] one of those rope swings where
they pull you up and you lay on your
stomach they pull you up and then they
you pull up on button then you drop yeah
but you go out over a [ __ ] thousand
foot canyon oh that's not I know I'm
[ __ ] really excited that you know how
they put they'll put two or three people
together in that thing and you're all
kind of like in a weird like you're in a
giant sleeping bag together I did that
once in Vegas with Scott Aukerman and
Brian Posehn you see three of us yeah is
that is that the one in old Vegas well
what no no MGM grand used to have it
when they had the worst amusement park
in the history of the world oh yeah I
remember that park in the back there the
rides were so late it was so lame was
trying to be like universal studios but
an empty yeah you know and riding the
roller coaster in New York New York's
pretty good that's neat yeah that's a
fun you know because New York's known
for its roller coaster the one Manhattan
is a roller coaster town the one over uh
the the one in at the NASCAR themed
restaurant the NASCAR wants pretty good
too good right yeah the way it kind of
shoots out of the side of the building
yeah and they all up and then shroom
right back don't want to know that
expression for when they shoot you out
of the station I don't know no I can
call my research don't call anybody um
yeah I uh I did the one where you they
pull you up on the in the sleeping bag
and drop you down rope swing I had to do
that one time like [ __ ] 21 times in a
row I was like I was rooting for that
game show I was the judge so I was I was
the host so I had to go up with the
contestants and I had an ear piece with
the timer and they and so the
contestants had to try to solve like
word problems that were on the ground
and the cement in the parking lot
outside of that ride so they pull us up
and then out in the sea met in the
parking lot they'd have these word
riddles and they had to solve it in like
45 seconds and I was with them and when
the 45 seconds is up I pulled him then
we'd swing on the ride and I had to do
it like 21 times row and i [ __ ] my
neck up and at one point I was like I
was like as I
feeling in my face and jason nash comes
already goes do not [ __ ] yourself up for
[ __ ] roller coaster tv's as i get
good call so I that they would Josh wolf
do that yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm telling you
what's the one uh it's not skyhawk in
Cedar Point it's the spinning max air I
don't know that max hair is the one it's
like a it's it's like um like one of
these big circle things that on a stick
and it spins and then pendulums oh yeah
I love that that Matt ride scare the
living [ __ ] out of me because it would
you can sit by where codes Ombey land
that ride like us they use it to smack
some zombies away well the movie
zombieland they get the zombies into an
amusement oh yeah and made that ride
it's like knock some zombies away at a
crucial moment yeah um because you can't
be standing you know you they've they've
they keep it so you can't stand under it
well it's going yeah if that ride freaks
me out because it almost goes
perpendicular and it's just one of those
things we like [ __ ] scary I hear the
ride the roller coasters in Europe or
[ __ ] bananas yeah that's what I keep
hearing as the best ones are there but I
also you know for some reason I keep
flashing on does New Jersey have like a
great one like one of the best roller
coasters some sorrow it's called bizarro
yeah I think familiar Pizarro's uh it's
it's got its got um it's got fire
elements in it I'm gonna get you your
answer right now and it's my answer
electromagnetic propulsion that's not it
that's not it but that's that's what I'm
talking about where's just the vicious
magnets the acceleration for the launch
is greatest at the beginning and dies
off rapidly towards the end of the
launch yeah here's one of these show one
of these ones wicked we could I know
wicked in uh in Utah oh we're kids in
Utah that's a fun [ __ ] ride you're
allowed to have fun in Utah oh that
[ __ ] ride is I love you say by the
way I'll come back soon ah linear
induction military's duction magnets are
the ones that just propel
you it like 90 miles an hour right away
just some and that's wicked in Utah
forget the name of the coaster park
hydraulic launch hydraulic lines can be
one of two things can be it can be
something that pushes you out or pulls
you like sometimes they have a cable
like I want to say they use hydraulic
fluid it's a nitrogen yeah it's like I
don't know if it's ty don't think it's
time to add extra but one of the ones
that I road is is a hook on the bottom
of the coaster and they build up the
pressure and then all of a sudden it
just reels in the the line that's
holding the coaster and that's how you
take off pneumatic pneumatic launch is
another one yeah there's probably a ton
ya know I'm like there's this like
article that's just going on on
electromagnetic pneumatic and hydraulic
launch systems are the most popular
catapult launches involve a large diesel
engine flywheel launchers I utilize a
large flywheel that spot of high speeds
and is attached to a cable that propels
the train forward friction wheel
launches what's it called when it's all
the incredible hulk at universals great
[ __ ] amazing right yeah it's a
perfect example of a friction wheel
launched coaster here's Utley funny we
did the incredible hulk and one with a
family and we the park to ourselves and
i'm with two young girls Phoebe and Lyla
I think their names i'm almost certain
and and so we send AJ and his mom and
his dad on to go to do the coaster and
I'm gonna sit with the girls and I'm
gonna get the my scream you sure too
small to do it I'm gonna get the my
scream will sit on the bridge and watch
them come by these girls are maybe like
six and eight okay so yeah so we're
eating ice cream the mom and dad going
and the girls are blown away they go and
they're like ah and I go they're going
twice they're gonna go twice so that
grows like oh my god I want to watch it
again so it comes by again but it's an
empty cart because clearly there's a
cart in between them and them there's
empty cart empty because oh my god where
are then I go they must have fallen out
oh but that's what you'd say to like an
adult right but is
78 year old I thought of their parents
were dead I love that I told her they
fell out I screams like waiter piece of
a bad joke ladies they know they're on
the next one happy that seems like
something would happen on an episode of
louie this stuff he does with his kids
is so funny seeing Louie at all oh my
god just recently his daughters like
really talking about how much she
enjoyed a movie she saw and after a
little while he realizes she's
describing Clockwork Orange he's like
you saw Clockwork Orange she's like this
guy's really bad so they pry his eyes
open Kylie so [ __ ] smart oh well I'm
sure he also you know that something
very similar probably happened with one
of his daughters oh my god damn it soon
as your kids see something you know is
not for kids oh like bummer georgia
georgia had watched her puberty they'd
watch a puberty video and uh in fifth
grade and they made us to prepare their
one of the parents to watch it first so
before they showed to the kids and the
sound wasn't synced up so it was just
two seconds off so all the questions
that these kids had to ask two adults in
this movie ended up just being Miss time
so that it looked like the adults were
asking the kids so it looked like the
uncle was saying to his nephew what does
it mean if my dick smaller than everyone
else is my penis is smaller than
everyone else's and then the kids like
been a very confident boys don't worry
Eric boys have different sized penises
it was [ __ ] hilarious what are you
doing oh yeah I
okay by the way I want to tell you we
just talked about roller coasters for
one hour no I know I thought I was kind
of like starting to feel like maybe
that's the one thing about periscope is
like if you're periscoping and talking
about roller coasters for too long the
comments would just start saying stop
talking about roller coaster yeah I
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but because we just we were
able to do what we wanted to do and
people can take the ride with us yeah or
not you know but we did talk for local
roller coasters are a really long time
like it with the kind of enthusiasm the
bad people talk about comedy with right
but that also that you just you know
like when you're at the amusement park
like standing in line all you do is talk
about I'll you know how great that last
ride was and what's what this next one's
going to be like and yeah it's also like
I mean I guess if people that you know
that might be one of the main things
that makes me makes me feel like I'm
staying relatively young is that I still
love that [ __ ] you know and a lot of
times I'm just there by myself and I'm
still having a ball yo because I just
once I'm on those rides they just it
just feels so great and it's so like
it's a great feeling and especially the
smooth the really good smooth ones that
they're you know constantly making now
that aren't all wooden and knocked the
[ __ ] out of you yeah I I'm getting out
of amusement parks after the day like
I'll go to the hotel and sit the jacuzzi
or something just to just to make sure
but you know I'm not like super hella
sore anything the next day or you know
how throw my neck or back out you know
yeah I I'm more likely to do that just
doing a regular everyday activity I've
been sitting in one of those coasters
because sometimes you're just trapped in
and you're just yeah you know nothing's
you know there's so much week have you
ever done a rope swing like a legit rope
swing overseas uh uh oh that that's what
you got to do that is like that those
are the best i'm trying to open one of
the states if anyone knows any stadiums
that want me to work with them i'd love
to do it it is we did it Moses Mabhida
Stadium in Durban and it it's like I
once a 504 and fifty feet and there's a
there's a line tied to the center of the
stab this stadium it's outdoors but it's
an indoor stadium kind of indoor/outdoor
Chum and then you climb up the spears
aspires so they're spires going up over
the stadium and that's what the things
hook two min senator
you climb up the spires on a pair of
stairs climb up over that spire onto a
catwalk and walk out 40 and 50 feet on
the catwalk they harness you in on a
5-point harness you jump and you free
fall arguably 420 of the 250 feet and at
the last 20 seconds you know inertia or
whatever you know the pendulum catches
you and you swing out it's a lot like
those rope swings that you see it like
like magic mountain the one that I was
talking about but it is on steroids I
did right because you you drop for so
much farther for [ __ ] four and a half
seconds and I once and then once you
swing do you have to is it like those
that you have just kind of swinging back
and forth for a while until it's over or
how do you how does it end um no it's
not I think I have one on my [ __ ] TV
to show you um you swing out and you
swing back and swing back and swing back
they had to put a harness on the one in
South Africa because people would swing
out and if the wind was kicking they'd
swing up and hit their [ __ ] face oh
yeah they want some woman hit her
[ __ ] face oh I can't wait to do this
no but it's but they have a break on it
you do him a lot in like new zealand
Switzerland Switzerland interlock ins
got the best one I've ever done
interlocking is the best rope swing I've
ever done it's a I forgot his car but
it's in this really tiny Canyon and you
jump off and you free fall for literally
45 seconds and the Rope catches you 10
feet off the ground and you swing
literally dependent lab of rocks like
what it is awesome it is the best yeah I
would want to take it i like i like
having these crazy sensations but as
safely as possible I don't need that
part where it like oh look at how close
you're coming to the rocks yeah I don't
need that part I could I rather drop 400
feet and still have another hundred feet
to the ground that's that's healing what
you're like 50 feet 40 like 100 feet off
the ground yeah you don't feel like it
yeah I don't need to have that extra
thing of like oh this is also seems
dangerously close yeah I just want to
feel like the great feeling of
plummeting that's why the one time I did
skydiving I was attached to a guy you
know him because I don't want to have to
I don't want to have to know when to
pull the thing or what to do yeah I
don't I don't either want to know any of
that [ __ ] yeah I all I've been Scott I
don't want to try to hit the ground
myself I want to have that guy you know
he hits first and then you hit
like you know that that's the thing all
these places that have skydiving people
are so terrified of it and think it's so
dangerous and there's they all have
perfectly clean records nobody ever gets
hurt people get hurt ankles no no no
like that we have a deaths are there
there's 48 a year at how many places in
how many jump average 48 a year oh
there's probably the percentage of
deaths is minuscule right cuz like
driving your car around every day in the
city is way more dangerous oh yeah any
of this [ __ ] Oh easily driving a car in
the cities date more dangerous than
skydiving and and you always go with a
guy or bungee jumping or any of these
things Oh budge is rope swings probably
safest out of all of them bungee then I
then I'd go I'd probably go skydiving
that bungees you ever hear about
somebody getting an eye injury bungee
jumping no I've never dude that actually
let me take that back the percentage of
fail in the majority of bungee companies
is zero grades never fail they never no
one's getting hurt at all bungee jumping
is that why bungee jumping isn't so big
anymore because it's so safe i I never
hear a CG job talking about it I loved
it when I you know I did it a bunch of
times I did an illegal one out in the
out in the mountains in the National
Forest outside of Reno really yeah how I
was some [ __ ] lunatic that like I
can't believe I did it like looking back
on him like why the [ __ ] did you do that
I've worked with those people before
yeah i mean just seemed like he knew
what he was doing took a group of us out
there had an escape plan if you know the
what do you columns roll up on you the
rangers services yeah if they roll up on
you you uh you know everybody's got a
bug-out plan even if you're the guy
doing the bungee you gotta you gotta
bail on bunging or get right back up you
know you know got shut down in their
zone and go yeah so but at night so it's
all like moonlight and flashlights you
went at night yeah middle of the night
me and Greg Barrett did it is one of the
craziest things and bring me off of a
bridge where you where your face gets
this close to [ __ ] rocks and stream
holy [ __ ] yeah sweet with the lunatic
where did you beat those guys
first bungee jump ever and I did it
under those circumstances that's [ __ ]
insane some guy that worked at the club
that we were playing in Reno we're
playing a catch a rising star in
whatever the hotel was called the time
and all photos of Harrah's or Hilton or
whatever because they switch them around
sometimes but it was in Reno and a guy
that works it was like hey do you guys
want to go on illegal bungee jump it's
like a hundred bucks or whatever and we
were like okay and you know even the
drive out there was scary you know
winding road we don't know this guy
that's driving us out there yeah and
sober are you sober uh no we probably
got drunk first you know we were because
it was after a night of shows in Reno oh
yeah ok so you don't work and you're so
weird s all drunk and high going out
into the middle of the [ __ ] National
Forest to go out into onto a bridge and
and what these guys set it all up and
then you illegal bungee jump and the guy
even has to make it even scarier by you
know I did the version where you just
fall off backwards yea the dead man's
drop yeah yeah that's scarier right then
just jumping off or which is their place
they're pretty scary I think that one's
scarier than just jumping off but i
think you know uh i think the harness on
your ankles is scarier to me than the
the other one was harnessed yeah the
hardest on your ankles is definitely a
more intense experience yeah i like the
waist harness cuz just cuz to get you
back up or to lower you whatever they're
going to do it's more comfortable so
this is ankle zand backwards drop equals
backwards drop over a [ __ ] River a
flowing river that you could see the
rocks haha out you know probably 200
feet or something holy [ __ ] so the guy
gets you out on like theirs and of a
thing you could stand on it gets me and
he's got my hands in both of his hands
and he goes ok now lean back and he goes
on 31 and just battled [ __ ] gag and
letting you go on one which as you're
falling you're pissed you know like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you but I guess also it
might just be something he got used to
doing because of the chicken out factor
you know if you're really counting to
three the person away no no you know
had people on the ledge going no no I
can't do it right one girl crying you
gotta [ __ ] do it at AJ Hackett's
place in in in Australia and she was
sobbing crying oh listen and this is the
truth this will all be over the second
you do it this will not murder you it's
not you're not murder you I will not
injure you you will it's scary but it's
it's fun scary trust me like people that
say they don't like roller coasters at
all it just baffles me that they they
can't just be open to the idea but Jim
notes a combination of things some
people are scared of heights just the
idea of heights not necessarily how
dangerous they are but just being hot
being up high I guess that's still day
that's dangerous or vulnerable but also
it's just this idea that there's going
to be an accident yeah drives me crazy
because I in our daily lives we do so
much [ __ ] that's so much more dangerous
yeah it's it's okay it's the best way to
access control danger yeah like it's
it's it's so much better to me than like
a scary movie I can't watch I haven't
seen a scary movie in a long time I
can't watch scary movie I well I think I
can't watch them cuz they're boring oh
yeah i'm bored by them oh they're
looking around for something eventually
it's going to jump out at them oh it's
an axe murderer oh she's got an axe in
her head you know like it's like it is
only so much of that i can see in my
life I've seen a thousand horror movie
yeah yeah and it just it's just so
repetitive and you know and then when
something comes along where people say
oh this has really got a new angle on it
it's just not it's not new enough for me
it's like that okay yeah I get it you
put a little bit of a spin on it but
it's still waiting for a shock and then
relaxing and then waiting for another
shock and then relaxing again but none
of them shocked me anymore cat jumping
out does not shock me because I'm
waiting for the [ __ ] cat to jump out
yeah you know I wonder how I wonder if
it's easier to write a horror movie or a
comedy yeah it's easier I mean horror
movies you can get away with not trying
in some ways you know or you know I do
like the I do like the mayhem in horror
movies you know when there's violence I
enjoy that I'm not against that I just
think that like a great example now is
just came out and I'll never see it as
human centipede part 3 and it's a
section 3 or whatever weird maybe gave
it its a you know the first movie was
three people in the second movie was ten
people now this one's 30 people or
something like that and they're sewed
together this mad scientist shows them
together ass to mouth yeah and then and
then they have exploits I don't know
what happens what's those people who
like that it's like when in tusk the
kevin smith movie once justin long turns
into a walrus for the rest of the movies
just a walrus just screaming about being
a walrus and you're just like yeah
you're stuck being a walrus so that's
how human centipede seems to me like oh
this is horrible was having these people
and what they can't run and jump in the
car and start it up and escape yeah
they're all sewed together it's 30
people so uh I'll never see that because
it just sounds disgusting yeah I don't
like movies where it breaks they break
my heart at the at the the taking of
someone's uh like humaneness that's
interesting I I don't necessarily
dislike a movie for that but it does it
does make me very sad like I really I
lose it hard over like uh you know
anytime little kids are in jeopardy in a
movie yeah I don't like that I get used
to it used to freak me out I don't know
what I don't know what movie this is by
saw movie as a kid about um the circus
would come in town and a clown would
come an account like remember it none it
Stephen King's it I didn't like it cuz
he was stealing little kids and then I
was like now he doesn't have a brother
and that would break my heart I'd be
like [ __ ] you can't do that man you
can't take a little brother let's not go
like that would freak me the [ __ ] out
that's what i don't like about SeaWorld
is that they separate the families and
now they got commercials saying they're
not separating the families and somebody
sent me you know I've been like
campaigning against the world if
somebody sent me a tweet today that in
[ __ ] Orlando they're going to build an
amazing roller coaster at SeaWorld and I
even tweeted just just mere weeks ago
somebody can back me up on this it's
probably still in my I might have
favored it it myself because sometimes I
favorite my own tweets because I want to
remember the joke or the sentiment later
[ __ ] small
are you know so but people like you
favor your own tweets like I'm like like
I'm that egotistical like this is it
this is a favorite designers not so not
even it's not that it's so good that i
took posted it it's even better yeah so
this one I wish I'd favorited it if I
didn't I gotta go find it or something I
said stop with the animal shows have a
have really cool aquariums I mean I
didn't say all of this it's too much for
one tweet but but my sentiment was make
put in more rides and just make it an
aquatic themed themed Park yeah we could
do that and they could do the [ __ ] out
of that and they could be competitive or
more so with all the other parks because
society is just gonna get tired of we've
seen there's plenty of footage of shamu
jumping up into the air yeah and kissing
somebody or whatever the [ __ ] they made
it do like I grew up on it I went to
SeaWorld yearly as a kid I lived I grew
up in San Diego SeaWorld was my favorite
thing after disneyland and it was closer
i love sea world yeah you know she watch
blackfish and it's so [ __ ] oh it's so
[ __ ] up I mean you look at them when
people give me a hard time like now also
like will you eat meat and they're doing
horrible things to all those animals to
get to your place oh I didn't know and
what fuel was until i went to a working
phone why don't evo I was like it always
assumed what we gonna show me huh what
were you gonna show me um cuz I gotta
wrap it up soon right yeah yeah how long
do you usually do this show for all
right I don't know I did my mail a short
one no no that's perfect um and I and I
could show it to the camera cuz I'm so
proud of it artist is a lady named Leah
to shown and this is not a photograph
this is this is drawn wood and it's my
new album's called promotional tool and
the cover is a parody or not a parody a
copy of taylor swift album with
me instead of Taylor Swift so when
people are [ __ ] around on iTunes they
you know they might click on it because
he might think it's taylor swift's
massive selling album i wonder if i
could get sued for doing something like
through being so tricky Tom Segura Tom
Segura named his album thrilled and he
was in the thriller position I thought
was a great I feel like I want to say
that I came up with it but I know I
didn't but like because but I was
definitely there when he was sitting at
dinner talking about it I guess it
qualifies his parody of course it does
get away with it yeah I wanted to call
mine next I don't know what I'm gonna
call my next i think i'm doing a call in
sick to work show for my next hour
special I'm gonna do it 11am in DC
that's awesome i'm doing from you i can
tell me when i took it from you a
hundred percent is I go into the clubs
like never do a show at 11am no but the
fact that you're I mean I what I did
have done so many of those with you like
your 420 shows that you see how happy
the [ __ ] Club is and you see how
packed out and you're in competition
with nobody that I started doing this I
do with the DC show the DC improv my
Douglas movies at 420 on that Saturday
the weekend you're going to be there has
been sold out for weeks weeks and it's
still weeks away still a few like three
or four weeks away by the way it's not
like that's when is it let's just plug
your date cuz cuz that's the fun part is
my show sold out so now it's just come
see Burt and hang out with us I think my
shows are sold out too there you go um
nobody gets her 11th 12th and 13th i
think that sounds about their nate is
that your date um um oh yes yes that's
going to be awesome i got two other doug
loves movies' regular so i'll keep a
secret for as a surprise and but that's
what i decided to take literally take a
page directly out of your book and i was
drinking doing radio anyway like I go in
they'd always have booze and then come
on come on Burt so I'd always drink take
shots or drink a cocktail or and then I
just figured [ __ ] it let's just go
straight to the club from here and do a
show right now and I the first one I did
was in DC
with Elia in the morning I go in I drink
on radio with him and then me and him
drove directly to the club and it sold
out in 20 minutes and so I was like
that's my new [ __ ] thing so I do I
did Tampa Edmonton I'm gonna do Phoenix
hey I'm gonna do a ball again dude you
got it you got to give me the dates and
I will happily come participate in some
way that would be fun I would be a blast
yeah you kidding me I did want to
Pittsburgh sold out uh it's a fun
[ __ ] gig but um I let you know I love
this [ __ ] you know like I this last
Mother's Day you know how comedy is on
Mother's Day like comedy clubs there
empty or they just do a lot of them
don't even bother you know a lot of
clubs are closed on Sundays anyway you
know and people don't bring their moms
to the comedy show at eight o'clock you
know like mom Mother's Day really does
kind of happen in the day and then that
night I everybody just sits around and
watch the 60 minutes or whatever the
[ __ ] mom wants to watch right so like
stand-up comedy I've never had a good
time on Mother's Day and then two years
ago I got the the brainstorm well I'll
just do a 420 show in Denver yeah
because they're so quite they're so into
weed there that like you know the ones
with or without their moms they're going
to come and some brought their moms and
then it sold out like it went from I
can't get people to come out at all on
Mother's Day to like now that I've got
this very specific audience yeah and
just people that like me in general I
mean I know I'd go to a show on Mother's
Day yeah I'll give a [ __ ] I go see my
favorite band on Mother's Day or
whatever yeah I don't know you see you
later mom yeah or you know a lot of
people don't have a mom you know various
reasons so you know and and or your
mom's not in the same town yeah like the
all these kids in Denver their moms
don't live there they just come to the
show you know that that's [ __ ] genius
so uh you know then I'd and fathers day
uh you know it's like now I'll just do a
show on Father's Day cuz it's like who
cares like there's plenty there's plenty
of families they can go about their
family like if I don't get the family
audience at all yeah there's still what
do I what's this country right now you
know the family audience is 200 million
and the rest is a hundred million people
yeah that's enough people for me to work
with as little as a base to entertain
potential
blown away doing your 420 show your 419
show when I was impressed with the night
before 420 we do a countdown like it's a
New Year's Eve seen anything like that
in my entire life I'm really being
serious I was blown away and what even
was more impressive and I me and full
Tron kept looking at it is how many
people wanted to get a picture with you
holding their pipe and taking a hit off
their pipe yeah that's a that is I mean
here I hear bucket list all the time I
go please get more important things that
you want to do before you die you you
must have taken a hundred hits yeah and
that's the thing is like that's another
thing that happens all the times people
are like they love to say I could smoke
you on the table or I can smoke more
than you yeah it's just like well how
was I wanted smoke more even mean I just
smoke and smoke and smoke and smoke yeah
I could smoke all day and night what are
you talking about at what point like one
time in Toronto I was at that comment
underground the underground or that
story [ __ ] green doubt there and like
that's like I you know that's the only
example of me ever that story every time
I nobody out smokes me I just [ __ ]
caved on my own yeah just just from a
room full of people out smoking me you
know like yeah it was it was too hard to
do stand-up comedy while people are you
know blowing smoke in your face oh I
done that club a number of times every
time I think I talk to you and you're
like bringing a list you're gonna forget
we were talking about I was like
strategy event every one of my sight do
you like dabs I love them but that's
where that's where it's truly like
people that dude abs and me that's where
the what's the expression the river
meets the road because even know if
that's an expression though something
hits the pavement yeah when that happens
it's in dabs like I can't I dabs will
knock me out like I think my record in
one like let's say day or a five-hour
period is maybe five dabs really and
that was you know I was pretty out of it
when it when I was done it only takes
one dab but then one day I will do you
will get your right there I would never
I'm
renew it out and it's probably smart
hard to car come on my show and do one
when your kids turn 18 let's let's write
that down somewhere when can you
officially did but I guess also who
knows you know who it's all seems to be
moving in the right direction in terms
of like acceptance but it's fun it's
it's a funny that some of my you know
best friends in comedy and in life in
general will not come on my show and
just sit there and smoke weed with its
will even though we do that in our lives
yeah the show's interesting because it's
it's I told you I'm obsessed with it
it's my favorite show I told you I want
to do getting Burt with drunk I'll do
that I'd appear on that because I could
drink for 45 minutes without you know
getting so crazy blasted yeah you know I
mean maybe that show would have to be
longer because we get pretty high in 45
minutes [ __ ] I saw the girl from
front Ponemah the girl from broad city
was like got really [ __ ] high the one
that was sitting next to you yeah yeah
he got really high and she's like a
daily smoker and I could see it in her
eyes I was like I was like she is
[ __ ] baked but when you like Jack
Black on yeah well he was you know he
wants to come back on like now he's
training for it goddamn it he's like a
smoking a little bit just to get better
it to build it up again because he had
just lost his tolerance through uh you
know having a family and a you know
career and yeah lots of you know he's a
like you know my friend Brian Posehn he
quit for a while like when when you know
when his kid was born or whatever it's
like I don't begrudge people on that
score at all it same thing as alcohol or
anything like I don't know why anybody
gives a [ __ ] what other people are doing
like you know it can kind of be a party
bummer like if you and I are hanging out
and you're like I don't want to smoke
tonight or if I said to you I don't want
to drink but you know you always kind of
want to be there's always this thing
where people want to be on the same
plane they want to be the same [ __ ] up
if they can be yeah but so many my
friends don't drink or smoke at all and
don't mind what I'm doing you know and
we all get along it's fine you know Liam
blank drink it all night I think every
time we go to dinner I have a glass of
wine
don't think I've gotten in a drunken
argument with a friend in like over a
decade because we're all just doing what
we want to do and doing what we can
handle you know like even when I'm
blackout drunk people tell me I'm not a
problem you know yeah I don't try not to
get blackout drunk but some days I wake
up and I'm like wow there was two hours
there I could have gone I could have
gone on a murder spree last night I got
pretty drunk I was with Stanhope's
manager and we were doing shots and i
was like i did ish i just don't do shots
that's hot that's how I that's why I
keep it under control as I just say no
two shots you're always of everyone
wanting to take a bong hit with you is
everyone gives me a shot everyone wants
do a shot with me imagine being Dave
Attell right now okay he just I think he
had to quit drinking zit was he couldn't
but you know i mean like he if he's in a
bar they're gonna offer him drinks like
they did not everybody got the memo that
he stole he doesn't drink I'd love to
know we must be hounded by it I'd love
to no way and he's such a sweet guy like
III he seems you getting nicer his time
goes on strangely enough oh my [ __ ]
they want me to do voiceover you gotta
get I gotta get going yeah well I'll do
voice I gotta go I'm gonna go pick up
the first box of my new CD that are
going to be available physical copies
you can get from a special thing records
com but you can get the digital download
which is the world's preference on
itunes on jun 9th well just a week from
Tuesday's out 2nite yeah she night
that's right before so you'll have them
at your 420 show in in DC oh well I say
I'm going to get some yeah I'll have one
they'll probably be one in the prize bag
other one but I don't smell I don't sell
[ __ ] of shows really no I'd rather go
outside and smoke with everybody I'm
gonna ask you before you leave that's a
tricky one though DC like there's no you
know the street lets out into like it's
oh no you can Otis to smoke yeah there's
late lets out into a really busy
Washington decent street but DC is super
down with weed I mean they really passed
it hard then really the recreational
yeah recreational is legal there now so
you do you have to get a license no he's
loved to do [ __ ] in DC yeah I
think they sell it but it's not illegal
to have it okay I don't think there's
dispensaries or anything what am hey
what's up before you leave I have to ask
you why did you decide to do a CD and
not an album or not a another DVD like a
like a video oh cuz i just did a video i
did a uh I've been doing an album a year
for this is the eighth album in eight
years yeah and uh just to you know sort
of like these guys that do like Louie
and Aziz to do a special once a year but
they they make it a TV special yeah I've
just been doing albums because I like
really got enamored with the george
carlin's output and with the idea of
having a lot of stuff out there because
I'd never done an album as of eight
years ago after already having been a
comic for quite long enough that I
should have done an album so the first
two albums are really good because they
are just out of the gate all the
greatest material from my first 10-15
years of stand up yeah you know then
every album since then has been a
panicked rush to get together enough
material for an album each year so this
is going to be the last one for a little
while really because also I just did my
first Netflix special and that seems to
have opened the doors forth and I can do
more of those if I want and so I'm
thinking about maybe dovetailing the TV
specials with the and the album's into
one thing instead of out instead of
doing both so what did you shoot that in
Denver you know will you make one and
it's both yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I don't want to do one for a
while because I really I'm really
exploring the idea of being more going
on stage with nothing and just trying to
do 45 minutes like not not Todd berries
crowd work to her or big Jay oakerson is
crowd work show this is more like there
will be crowd work because there has to
be but they're more more it's just about
me just like deciding what I want to
talk about sort of based on what the
crowd wants me to talk about yeah you
know I mean yeah yeah yeah because i
think that like you know what they want
is what they should get yeah you know at
some people at this point probably don't
enjoy like my my written stand-up
material because they they associate me
with all these other things where i'm at
libbing all the time
you know make sense you know ya like
like my stand-up some people wanna be
like he doesn't talk about movies enough
in his tandem some people might watch my
movie podcast ago he doesn't talk about
being high enough you know so it's like
usual you do all these things and
hopefully people find the ones that work
for them where did you shoot your next
photo special at the neptune theatre in
a a seattle over near you dub a
beautiful theater and they have these
glass windows stained glass windows that
are all neptune team they're all
nautical and throughout the theater
they've got like it's just got on the
whole place they've just really done it
over nicely it's an old theater called
the neptune and they just did a whole
nautical theme and it's really pretty
and cool and when people take their
comedy specials there they cover up the
stained glass windows and put a set up
yeah so we put a set in the back because
when special was called duck dynasty so
we put a bunch of ducks flying across
some clouds behind me yeah but then and
that's also why there's ducks on my
shirt I was on what Taylor Swift mallard
duck so she's got a cheese got some sort
of bird on her shirt and Meinhard mine
of the duck similar the Ducks from
dynasty and then we left but we left the
stained glass windows and then it became
like a running thing through the through
the show jokes about the stained glass
windows but but I just thought the place
looked really cool so why go in there
and cover him up you know I I wanted to
do it in that the company that did the
special came to me and said you know
what do you think of the Neptune that
was like one of the I think that was
their second suggestion and I said yes I
think they asked me where I wanted to go
and I pick some theater that for one
reason or another was too expensive I
forget which theater i picked what's
your favorite theater to play I gotta
get going yeah I don't do I don't do
theaters enough hello to theaters at all
barely what's your but if you like if
you like here in LA the one that I sort
of want to conquer as I'd like to do
something at the wiltern I'd love to do
the oh oh yeah oh yeah I totally do
something at the wiltern i love the
wiltern i think the world turns [ __ ]
badass
on the other hand I never want to be on
stage at the Hollywood Bowl I thought
I'd love to be on stage the Hollywood
Bowl it's just so vast carnegie hall and
it was too big how about what's the one
in and i'll go strap carnegie hall and
you're asking me about those felis the
Greek the Greek I like the Greek yeah
all right I'm know what else I didn't I
never asked for something to drink or
may you offer it may be and I just
didn't say anything do you feel the
drink well it's just weird that I'm so
cotton mouth right now because just been
it's odd to do a podcast and talk for
this long and not take one sip of
anything just been hitting the pipe and
look at it looking at these Reese's
Pieces oh they're [ __ ] good I was
thinking of that as a category ID
Douglas movies reese's pieces like
movies where you see Reese Witherspoon's
tits or something like that you could do
a category of naughty bits you have the
greatest names of albums ever well thing
I'd like you to name my albums would be
good I was thinking about doing one live
her with like all the [ __ ] lights
like in that bar thing just lights and
it says live ur Bert Kreischer live ur
but it's gonna look like liver you
should go on tour with the o-neders all
right i'll let you go I'll cake my guys
thank you so that was the podcast
everybody and it was brought to you by
audible.com I want to thank audible com
and I'm gonna tell you this right now
get this book you get a free one it's
the life-changing magic of tidying up
the Japanese art of decluttering and
organizing by Marie Kondo condo KN kon
do it is yours if you want to listen to
it Ultimo's got it they've got a 180,000
audiobooks and spoken word audio
products and you are going to find what
you were looking for so get it get a
free audiobook and a 30-day trial period
today by signing up at www.bobcat com
backslash Burke cast declutter your life
streamline it I'm trying to get rid of
clothes right now my daughters were in
the backyard they're driving me [ __ ]
nuts he shows over new podcast
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you